mike minder pitched for chris woodward
he was with the rangers for three years
he was an all-star in 2019 and then last
year
pitching for the rangers and then the
a's he was just one in six with a 5.56
era
did well against lefties
last year
but today he's down on strikes going
after a high fastball and it's a good
start
for mike miner
it brings up david dowell
left hinders breaking ball and that's
lifted out to left center field then
carrying well it gets down base hit
so dull will cruise to second base with
a one out double
his second double of the year already
and out there in scoring position for
joey gallo
miners one two and that ball is hammered
high and deep to center it is gone
joey gallows first long ball of the
season
and a no doubt shot to center
another great first inning start for
this rangers team
kohei arahara making his
major league debut big day for
kohei
arahara and for the rangers
that rolled up the middle could be two
flipped to second one and the relay in
time double play
up comes
michael taylor
bouncer third culverson with the bare
hand and he takes care of taylor for a
quick one two three
second inning for arihara
miners all at second gallow at first
and that's inside actually got a piece
of his elbow
[Applause]
so a hit batter loads them up
so doll at third gallow at second solak
at first
and lo the batter
and low shoots that one through base hit
dahl is in gallow right behind him a
two-run single by nate lowe and the
rangers lead four-nothing
and that will bring to the plate
salvador perez
salvi hits it well to right field gallow
is back and it's going to be over his
head and off the top of the wall gallow
makes a strong throw back to the infield
but salvi
is in there with a double
solaire reached base every time he came
to the plate
and six plate appearances on thursday in
the air
and that one hit pretty well out to left
white might have room he does and the
inning is
and done had a huge opening day
three for five with a home run a couple
of outfield assists three of their last
four outs have been in the air and
there's one in the air that's deep into
center field and michael a taylor ladies
and gentlemen
that was a bomb to straight away center
and it is 4-1
in the fifth
now isbell is reaching but he pops one
to center
tavares
angling away from the sun and he lost it
his bell will end up at third base with
nobody out
oh man is
kyle isbell going good or what and how
about this one here you could tell he
just didn't have his body at the right
angle and this young rookie tavares he's
never played here before in the sunday
like day so this is uh you got to take
advantage of it isabel running the whole
way taking his time cruising all the way
to third base a break for the royals
with nobody out a man in third
handser already has a double today and
that's well hit right center field and
that will be down
it is 4-2
and alberto has two doubles
in his two-at-bats today
nikki lopez is expected to do the little
things
and right here move that runner to third
base with less than two
and nicky bunts that'll get the runner
over and that'll get nikki a base hit
and the royals do hit for the cycle
and the tying run is at first base with
nobody out and i guarantee you the texas
rangers are going uh-oh here they come
wit wants to elevate look up in the zone
for something
whit grounds it
out to the second baseman
solac no double play it's a one-run game
whit picks up an rbi as alberto comes
down from third
and lopez is out at second
look at him he's digging don't watch the
ball face runners concentrate on first
base that's where you're going to be
so eli white comes up with
two outs of nobody on
the 01 is swung on hit left center field
ben and tendy coming on dives and makes
a terrific catch oh he took the page out
of alex gordon's book
andrew benintendi
and mike miner immediately turned and
saluted him here we are bases loaded
nobody out
oh well hit right field gallow is back
and it's going to be over his head
taylor will drive in two
santana and salvi come to the plate the
royals lead
and the michael a taylor show continues
here is this bell now he's got a chance
to win it and now isabelle slices one to
left center and that's down
another run is home
isbell gets another rbi
and the royals have six runs in the last
two innings and they lead by two you
just can't contain them how about the
rookie isbell so they're in good hands
with merrifield who loves left-handed
pitching
and whitney hits a ground ball base hit
left field
taylor's home here's isbell
white's throw is just a little bit late
isbell's fired up
so is the crowd as the royals have five
in the sixth
and here's the guy who started all this
carlos santana
line up the line fair and that's going
to go all the way down into the corner
alberto scores here's whit around third
the relay is
not in time and santana goes all the way
to third
and the royals are running wild at
kauffman stadium
and there's
the
family and friends
in tears
as the baseball dream
comes true in kansas city for
jake brents
and he gets a strikeout
his first big league strikeout
and here comes mike matheny
he's going to allow
jake brent to
finish his big league debut on a high
note
yeah look at all the love his teammates
are giving him on the top of that rock
there that top of that mountain in the
mound there
for a major league debut that will never
be forgotten
one out to win mere field
that balls hit well to left field guzman
is back
reaching for the fence and it's gone
that's merrifield's second home run in
two games and he has driven in four
today
[Applause]
uh-oh watch this
oh the royals are still working hard on
defense with a seven run lead in the
ninth inning
center field taylor
fights the sun and he's got it he had
another
big game on offense
so did the royals as a team with 11 runs
two more home runs
with merrifield drove in four
and it was a much better pitched game
today than it was on thursday